und jetzt das heute
journal dieser Wunsch Volg schbles einen
Franzosen im Bundestag sprechen zu
lassen sagt viel über sein Vertrauen in
unsere beiden Länder es sagt aber auch
viel über unsere
Geschichte und über uns
zft Moment der wird auf deutsch im
Deutschen Bundestag beschwört der
französische Staatspräsident Emmanuel
macron die Freundschaft beider Länder
und er erfüllt seinem Freund Wolfgang
Schäuble damit einen letzten Wunsch
guten Abend der Staatsakt heute für
Schäuble den an Weihnachten Verstorbenen
ausnahmepolitiker war in gleich
mehrfacher Hinsicht bemerkenswert auch
weil er im Gedenken an eine
Lebensleistung nach vorne blicken ließ
Frank
Buchwald
keiner gehörte länger dem Bundestag an
kaum einer trug seinen Namen so in die
Geschichte Deutschlands und Europas ein
Wolfgang Schäuble ein vollendeter
Staatsdiener so würdig ihn die
Bundestagspräsidentin natürlich er
behielt gerne Recht und oft genug gab
ihm die Geschichte recht und wenn einmal
nicht dann hat er dazu bestanden der
Kompromiss als politische Kunst so er
TLE den Respekt seiner Gegner und seiner
Freunde in Koalitionen im Kabinett und
in der Krise loyal an der Seite seiner
Kanzlerin er war streng nicht nur gegen
sich selbst sondern auch gegen andere
aber das hilft ja dann manchmal auch die
Zukunft besser zu gestalten Merkel
würdigt ihren Weg Gefährten im ZDF
Interview cduf merärz zitiert aus
Schäubles Antrittsrede als
Bundestagspräsident Freiheit
Rechtsstaatlichkeit sozialer
Zusammenhalt ische Nachhaltigkeit ohne
Parlamentarismus geht all das nicht
bewegende Worte dann von Frankreichs
Präsident macron in deutscher Sprache
Deutschland hat einen Staatsmann
verloren Europa hat eine Säule
verloren frankreich hat einen fr
verloren Deutschland nimmt Abschied von
einem
schäule wird fehlen nicht nur in
Berlin wenn Klaus weselski zum Streik
ruft dann gibt es praktisch niemanden in
Deutschland den oder die das nicht
trifft Bahnkunden warten vergeblich auf
ihren Zug Autofahrer steht im Stau
Unterricht fällt aus die Wirtschaft
leidet und und und jetzt ruft der
bekannteste gewerkschaftter in
Deutschland zu einem Streik der selbst
für
lockführerverhältnisse speziell ist
136 Stunden der längste Streik überhaupt
bei der Deutschen Bahn im
Personenverkehr ab Mittwoch 2 Uhr früh
die Bahn sagt das sei absolut
unverantwortlich die Gewerkschaft fühlt
sich vom Bahnvorstand veralbert Stefanie
Hein und Niels Schneider mit mehr
dazu fahrende Züge ab Mittwoch wird das
ein seltener Anblick sein wer reisen
will oder muss sollte sich lieber
Alternativen überlegen Reaktionen aus
Berlin ich glaube schon dass es wichtig
ist für lohnererhöhung zu kämpfen und da
habe ich Verständnis für ja die sollten
auch ein bisschen kompromissbereiter
sein und vor allen Dingen auch mal
schauen dass andere
Bevölkerungsschichten ja auch nicht
alles durchsetzen können was sie gerne
hätten die GDL fordert eine 35 Stunden
Woche für Schichtarbeiter bei vollem
Lohnausgleich die Bahn bietet 37 Stunden
an allerdings unter dem Vorbehalt dass
sie genügend Personal findet die GDL
fühlt sich so nicht ernst genommen der
Personalvorstand der Bahn Seiler würde
tricken und Täuschen verhandeln wird die
GDL wenn klar ist dass Herr Seiler keine
Vorbedingung stellt und nicht die
vahgäste und auch seine eigenen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen veralbert wenn
klar ist dass dieser Bahnvorstand mit
uns in Verhandlung Eintritt über alle
Elemente die wir gefordert haben der
Chef der Deutschen Bahn fordert
Kompromissbereitschaft statt endlich zu
verhandeln stürzt sich die GDL in den
nächsten langen Streik unter dem das
ganze Land leidet Ökonomen schätzen den
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Schaden eines
streiktages auf bis zu 100 Millionen
Euro der Bundesverkehrsminister mahnt
wenn Güterverkehre nicht fahren können
nicht pünktlich gefahren werden all das
schwächt unsere Gesellschaft und
deswegen tragen diejenigen die
leichtfertig immer wieder zu Streik
aufrufen auch eine große Verantwortung
anders als beim letzten Mal will die
Bahn diese Woche nicht versuchen den
Streik vor Gericht zu verhindern
ja und Fragen an Gewerkschaftschef
weselski nachher hier bei uns im heute
journal Update israel hat eine Menge
Feinde gerade in der eigenen Region
israel hat aber auch enge Freunde und
Partner und ausgerechnet die hat Israels
Regierungschef jetzt enorm vor den Kopf
gestoßen mit seiner Ansage ein
Palästinenserstaat komme für ihn nicht
in Frage die brüske Absage an eine
Zweistaatenlösung die politgäste in
Israel bei uns en Staatsbesuchen in
Pressekonferenzen und diplomatischen
runden immer wieder händes schüttelnd
bekundet hatten speziell Israels Partner
in den USA und in Deutschland stehen
jetzt ziemlich bedröppelt da die
Europäische Union macht ihrem Ärger
darüber heute Luft und versucht sich
gleichzeitig vorsichtig an einer Lösung
zumindest waren die Chefdiplomaten aus
Israel und von den Palästinensern heute
in Brüssel gleichzeitig wenn auch nicht
gemeinsam Gunar Krüger
Israels Außenminister hält der EU vor
Augen warum sein Land den Kampf in Gaza
weiterführen müsse es ist von großer
Dringlichkeit es ist sehr wichtig sie
schnell
zurückzuholen zugleich muss Israel um
die EU kämpfen um ihre Unterstützung
denn darum müht sich gleich darauf vom
Protokoll getrennt noch ein
Außenminister im Namen der
Palästinenser
ich erwarte dass sie zu einem
Waffenstillstand aufrufen und sich dafür
einsetzen ich erwarte dass sie Netanyahu
für seine Ablehnung der zwei
staatenlösung
verurteilen Samstag hatte Israels
Regierungschef gesagt mit der Kontrolle
über das Palästinensergebiet sei dessen
Souveränität unvereinbar darum lautet
der Vorwurf heute Vertragsbruch wenn die
Israelis glauben dass die zweienlösung
keine Lösung ist dann sind sie ziemlich
isoliert das sind kurzsichtige
Äußerungen ich sehe keine anderen Weg es
ist die only game in town Normalisierung
und zwe sten Lösung so kommt Kritik
selbst von denen die damit sonst sparen
ein Staat der Palästinenser galt gilt
als Schlüssel zum Frieden we diejenigen
die davon nichts wissen wollen haben
bisher keine andere Alternative auf den
Weg gebracht Ergebnis heute die EU plant
eine
Friedenskonferenz und ist eine
Militärmission im Roten Meer der Schutz
vor den hutis sei so der
Außenbeauftragte auch ein Beitrag zu
mehr Sicherheit in der
Region so den Blick auf das was heute
auch noch wichtig war den hast du jetzt
Heinz der neue polnische
Ministerpräsident Tusk will mehr
westliche Hilfe für die Ukraine
mobilisieren Tusk nannte das ein
Hauptziel seiner Reise heute nach Kiev
nach seinem Treffen mit Präsident
selenski Versicherte Tusk Polen werde
weiterhin alles in in seiner Macht
stehende tun um die Chancen der Ukraine
auf einen Sieg in diesem Krieg zu
erhöhen wie Tusk unterstrich selenski
dass Polen damit auch seine eigene
Freiheit
wre der Preis für das deutschlandticket
auch 49 € Ticket genannt soll in diesem
Jahr stabil bleiben darauf hat sich die
Verkehrsministerkonferenz der Länder
geeinigt das deutschlandticket gibt es
seit Mai vergangenen Jahres und damit
kann der regional und Nahverkehr
bundesweit für monatlich ne € genutzt
werden Kamerun hat die weltweit erste
Impfkampagne gegen Malaria gestartet
vorgesehen ist eine vierfachimpfung von
Babys und Kleinkindern an Malaria
sterben jährlich mehr als 500.000
Menschen vor allem Kinder unter 5 Jahren
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation spricht
angesichts der gestarteten Impfkampagne
in Afrika von einem historischen
Schritt eine Meldung vom Sport bei den
Australian in Melbourne hat Tennisprofi
Alexander zwerf sein Achtelfinalspiel
gewonnen gegen den breten Cameron Nori
in fünf Sätzen und im Viertelfinale
trifft SF auf den Weltranglisten zweiten
Carlos aikaras aus Spanien jetzt noch
die Wetteraussichten morgen wechselnd
oder stark bewölkt und zunächst nur
einzelne Schauer nachmittags ganz im
Westen aufkommend der Regen bei starkem
Westwind 4 bis 9° am Mittwoch milde 8
bis 14° und dazu sehr nass und windig
mit schweren sturmböhnen am Donnerstag
und Freitag weiterhin wechselhaft und
windig bei 5 bis 12°. so jetzt gleich
viel mehr Sport wir zwei sagen danke für
Ihr Interesse an einem kurzen
heutejournal morgen mehr und weisen noch
auf unser heutejournal Update um 33:50
Uhr mit nasang göckte mir hin Ihnen ein
angenehmen Abend und viel Spaß beim
Handball
[Musik]
wiedersehen